نسور جارحه لا تخطئ هدفها ترصد فريستها ثم
تنقض عليها لتفتك بها هذه النسور سرعتها
قد تصل الى 320 كيلومترا في الساعه وما
تشاهدونه هو تقليد الصيد بالطيور الجارحه
الذي يعود للقرن العاشر الميلادي في اسيا
الوسطى منذ اكثر من سته الاف عام سكان
المنطقه لا يزالون يواظبون على ممارسه
تقليد الصيد بالنسر الذهبي
النسر الاضخم في سلالته الاقليه
الكازاخستانيه التي تعتبر ثاني اكبر اقليه
في منغوليا ويقطن معظم افرادها في مقاطعتي
بيان ايفي وهوفد هي من تحرص على اقامه هذا
التقليد فاجدادها هؤلاء المصطفين هناك
كانوا يعيشون على الصيد بالطيور الجارحه
جد هذا الرجل مثلا كان يستعين بنسره
المدرب يطلق له العنان لجلب فريسه من اجل
اطعام اسرته
ومن يمسك من النسور بفرائس اكثر ويجلبها
لراعيه كان يمنح لقبا نسر الذهبي ولهذا
توارثت الاجيال هذا اللقب ومن ثم اقاموا
له مهرجانا خاصا في محافظه اولغي
الكازاخستانيه الشهيره وتعرف ايضا بمنطقه
المنغوليه التي يسكنها بعض من الشعوب
الكازاخستانيه
اعيش في مقاطعه بيان اولجي واناهز من
العمر 67 عاما كنت ادرب النسور على مدار
36 عاما ارتاد المهرجان اربع مرات في
مقاطعه وست مرات في العاصمه ان الصيد
بالنسر تقليد عائلي وقد مارسه والدي ايضا
[موسيقى]
يرتدي المشاركون في مهرجان النسر الذهبي
الملابس التقليديه كما يقومون بتزيين
خيولهم ويجرون سباقا للخيول مستخدمين
النسور الذهبيه في الصيد وبعد نهايه
السباق يحصل الفائز على كاس المهرجان الذي
يقام بصفه دوريه كل عام
في مجمع قصر جنكيز خان السياحي في عاصمه
منغوليا
يستعرض ابناء الاقليه الكازاخستانيه
مهاراتهم في الصيد بالطيور الجارحه ولا
يقتصر الامر على ذلك بل ان هناك هدفا اعمق
لهذا المهرجان وهو نشر الثقافه
الكازاخستانيه
ان الغايه من المهرجان هي تعريف سكان
العاصمه والسياح بالثقافه الكازاخستانيه
حيث لا تتسنى للجميع زياره مقاطعه بيان
اولجي كما انه يرمي الى مشر ثقافه الصيد
بالنسور
لا يدخل هذا المهرجان صياد نسور ضعيف
المستوى بل لابد من ان يكون من نخبه من
مدرب النسور في البلاد حيث يتم انتقاء
صياد الافضل على اساس معايير السرعه
والدقه والرشاقه فالصيد بالنسر تقليد
عائلي ممتد لالاف السنين
نظم المهرجان بهذا الشكل لسنوات عديده حيث
يتنافس نخبه من مدربي النسور في بيان
اولغي والافضل هو من يحظى بفرصه المشاركه
في مهرجان العاصمه
مهرجان النسر الذهبي بدا في عام 2008
وينطلق كل عام بمشاركه نحو 19 صيادا كل
منهم يمتلك نسرا ذهبيا لديه القدره
الهائله على اصطياد الارانب والحيوانات
الاخرى ويحترف الصيادون الذين يعرفون باسم
بيركوتشي او كوزبيجي هذا التقليد منذ
الطفوله ويحافظون عليه جيلا بعد جيل